yummy yummy yummy in my tummy tummy
tummy hello friend
zest
boost it is granted I did only upgrade
from the iPhone 14 but immediately I
noticed just swiping through opening
apps everything just felt faster and
even in past iPhone upgrades I don't
really remember having that feeling so
I'm not sure what's going on here with
the a17 pro but it does feel noticeably
faster the other thing that I was quite
surprised about is I don't really think
they did any huge upgrades to the front
facing camera but it feels like they did
now I take a lot of photos sitting here
at this desk and for whatever reason
sometimes the photos don't really look
that great especially using the
front-facing camera the iPhone really
thrives in those everyday situations so
the lighting that I have here is set
more specifically for these cameras but
these pictures that I took of me and
Maddie like they just looked so crisp
the lighting was very even like
everything about it is just I was so
surprised how great this turned out
which made me kind of excited to start
using the front-facing camera more like
even this looks better I don't know if
it's some sort of new algorithm or
something it feels much better I like
that you can easily switch between the
raw 12 megapixel front facing you can
turn it on or turn it off right there
when I was working on my review the
thing that I was most excited about was
the pro res raw shooting now in everyday
scenarios like I'm not gonna be shooting
in prores raw but just going through and
editing that footage was so much fun
because I really got to take advantage
of coloring that all completely myself
but since then I haven't really done
anything that I've really needed to film
in Pro res raw so I feel like on a
day-to-day basis it's not going to be
something that I'm using daily but when
I do really want to get some awesome
shots the fact that this has so much
power in this camera is so awesome
here's an example of a night photo that
I took while I was in New York this was
at 5am and thankfully the streets were
completely empty so I was able to get
this shot in the middle of the street I
love taking night photos and I feel like
this is the perfect combination between
low lights but just a little bit of
street lights kind of lighting up the
scene and some light from behind to kind
of light up the sky so it really gives
you this awesome super crisp shot before
we continue a huge thank you to pulseway
for partnering with me on this video
Let's head to itjustine to tell us more
about it
super cool dude 85 wants to know what's
the best it management app well super
cool dude 85 there are a lot of options
out there but I would definitely
recommend pulse way pulseway is built to
help reduce downtime and set new
standards for efficiency through
automation they offer a full it stack of
software and services to help you look
after all of your it needs plus they
have a very handy mobile app that puts
the entire ID infrastructure in the palm
of your hand so you can manage from
anywhere you can get real-time alerts
Auto remediate it problems and take
action instantly from any device thanks
to pulseway Native mobile apps pulseway
helps keep your systems running smoothly
so you can focus on what matters the
most don't let issue slow you down and
take control of every system experience
the power of pulseway at your fingertips
with a free trial and special offer
using the link below in the description
check it out I hope that answers your
questions super cool dude 85.
so moving on a lot of the big updates
that I feel like people mostly notice is
the fact that you do have a new iOS
software update and of course I did make
a whole video on talking about some of
all of the iOS 17 updates but again I
freaking love the stickers like I can't
get over it I just keep like making
other people's accidental live photos
into stickers and it's really funny now
name drop and airdrop by like you know
touching the phones together it has been
working most of the time I'm not sure if
I've completely figured out how it
actually works see there's been a few
times where I've thought that I was
airdropping somebody something and then
it didn't work or at least I didn't
think it worked and then I went to
airdrop it again and I it wasn't working
but then I went and airdropped it again
and then they proceeded to get three
versions of everything that I just sent
them so I've accidentally airdropped
three times so I'm not really sure if
that's just user error or I'm not sure
sometimes there's these little
notifications that'll keep popping up
over and over that's like airdrop except
except and then it disappears so this
happened to me the other day and it just
kept happening and I was like what's
going on I've also really really been
enjoying all of the updated sounds
[Music]
[Applause]
like it's very slight but it's like they
added a few more little tiny Chimes and
I I really like it a lot now another
little sound that I like
that's not new
where's it at
there's a sound that I'm trying to find
but I can't find it can you like my
photo or something on Instagram because
it's an Instagram Sounders I mean
Instagram message
isn't that new said instead of me more
than me now
is that just Instagram send me something
on Tick Tock now
okay it must be the the notifications
I've never heard it before until now and
I love it
that's one of my favorite new things is
that little notification sound I love it
so much now when I was doing my review
originally I was super hyped about
action mode and changing it and
customizing it and I just realized that
most of the time I just pick the camera
right from here so I have changed my
action mode button wait for it sit down
I don't know if you're ready for this I
changed it to silence my iPhone
it's great it's great out of all the
things that I could have done that's
what I have it doing now silencing my
iPhone maybe I'll change it later maybe
I'll make some big elaborate shortcut
that does something really cool but for
now it's silencing my phone and I'm
gonna continue to use my camera from the
home screen the other thing that I have
been loving so much is the 5x telephoto
camera it is so crisp and so clear I
know this is kind of ironic that I went
to a Microsoft Event right after the
Apple event so here's a few photos that
I took while they were on stage
presenting the new Surface laptop go and
the new Surface studio 2. and I was so
impressed like this looks like I was
using some sort of telephoto camera on
like a big you know mirrorless camera
but no just shot on iPhone and actually
this photo that my sister took I'm gonna
steal this from her we were I don't know
where we were going I'm not sure what
we're doing we're in the car passing the
airport and she took this really cool
photo of a plane like she just went like
this oop took it and then I looked at
the picture I was like oh my gosh this
is like some sort of well not National
Geographic I don't know something that
would be award-winning it was an
award-winning photo good job Jenna the
other thing that I've been loving is you
guys may have seen the video that I
posted diving with the new iPhone 15
taking this thing out diving was so much
fun and especially being able to use
this dive housing by Oceanic plus it was
such a great experience and just looking
back at some of this footage it looks so
crisp and so clear and I'm so excited to
go diving again so I can't wait to do
that the other thing is when I ordered
my phone I was freaking out because I
didn't know which case I wanted so
here's a few of the cases that I got my
favorite combination though I think is
this black fine woven case and I kind of
wish I would have got a fine woven black
wallet but I do have the purple one here
and I think this combination looks
pretty good another thing that took me
by surprise is the slickness of the fine
woven cases I pretty much wear yoga
pants with pockets I mean that's that's
basically all I wear maybe you know once
a quarter I'll put on a pair of jeans
and I'm very unhappy about it but I was
going for a run the other day and I had
my phone and the fine woven case in my
pocket and I had my air pods on so I
couldn't really hear anything I had the
you know the noise cancellation on and
all of a sudden my pocket felt empty and
I look I looked down
I feel for my phone it's gone completely
just not even here and I turn around and
it's like I don't know like 20 30 feet
back on the trail I was like I did not
even hear it fall and because my pants
are so slick I didn't even feel it
leaving my pocket this actually happened
back at camera Camp yes first camera
Camp so iPhone 12. Sarah and I she was
chasing me or something I don't remember
what we were doing but I didn't have a
case on my phone and it was in my pocket
and it slipped out oh come on
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess take a picture
very similar to that so pretty much all
in all I've been loving the new phone
and it really does feel like much more
of an upgrade than I thought I was
initially thinking like oh I'm not gonna
be able to tell the difference of the
photos no I mean I can tell the
difference in the front-facing camera
and they didn't even change that like
something is different I don't know what
they did but it looks so much better the
titanium is also very pretty I'm very
very happy that I ended up going with
the natural it is more of a white color
than I thought it was going to be
because even when we were looking at
this at the Apple event like it seemed
like it had more of uh like brownish
kind of a yellowish Hue but I think it
was just the lighting in the building
because now here having it in the studio
having it out and about it really kind
of just looks like a silverish color and
it matches the Apple watch Ultra
perfectly the other thing is how light
this is it's so wild like it just feels
so light and it is a noticeable
difference especially coming from the 14
where the edges is are really they're
sharp like they're I just I would be
scared like that could be used as a
weapon on the streets but now they're a
little bit more rounded and does feel
much comfier in your hand and I've seen
so many people who are going caseless
and I just I want to do that so bad but
knowing how many times I've already
dropped this phone and I've only had it
for two weeks I'm really not proud of
myself so those are some of my initial
thoughts and how I'm feeling about the
new iPhone 15 Pro Max I would love to
hear from you guys did you guys get your
phones I've been enjoying seeing
everyone's reactions and unboxings like
that's all I've watched now that mine
are all done it's been so fun seeing how
excited everybody is and all of the
unique ways that they have been using
their phones and shooting such
incredible videos so I've loved seeing
them and if you've made any videos
please send them to me on Twitter X I
will not I whatever you know what I mean
send them to me there and look forward
to checking those out if you want to
watch any more videos that I have posted
here from apple season check them out
here on the end or you can find more on
my YouTube channel youtube.com iJustine
see you in the next video peace